[Music]
between high stakes fighter jet combat
and massive personalities on set
director tony scott had a lot to deal
with while he was working on top gun but
believe it or not it was the movie's
famous volleyball scene that almost got
the director fired before top gun soared
to the top of the box office in 1986
director tony scott was best known for
directing the cult vampire film the
hunger starring david bowie and susan
sarandon while scott went on to become
one of the most successful directors in
hollywood by helming such hits as
beverly hills cop 2 and days of thunder
it was top gun that propelled him to
a-list status in the late 1980s but
despite his accomplishments behind the
camera he almost lost his jaw because of
one iconic scene
son your ego is writing checks your body
can't cash
in a well-known nearly two-minute scene
sweat glistened pilots maverick goose
iceman and slider play a game of
volleyball while the kenny loggins song
playing with the boys blasts in the
background the director spoke about the
scene for danger zone the making of tom
gun a documentary featured on the
movie's 30th anniversary blu-ray and dvd
i didn't have a vision about what i was
doing other than just doing
soft porn
on the june 3rd episode of the hollywood
reporters behind the screen podcast
chris lebenson and billy weber who were
nominated for oscars for their editing
on top gun revealed that at least one
paramount studios executive was irate
upon discovering scott spent an entire
day filming the volleyball scene which
in the script only consisted of a single
paragraph according to lebanzon the
volleyball scene may have looked like a
relaxed fun time but it didn't go over
so well with paramount lebanzon recalled
that scene was scripted as a real game
they kept score and everything and tony
shot it like a commercial and paramount
was angry billy weber further revealed
director tony scott almost lost his job
after filming the volleyball scene that
has now become so iconic that it was
reimagined for the 2022 sequel top gun
maverick according to weber the studio
was so pissed off the head of production
charlie maguire he said i'm gonna fire
him because he spent a whole day
shooting the scene and then of course it
turns out it's one of the most famous
scenes in a movie to pay tribute to the
fan favorite scene top gun maverick sees
maverick arrange a game of dog fight
football for the hot-headed graduates
from the top gun academy he's been
tasked with preparing for a dangerous
mission fans got a sneak peek of the
sequence in the earliest trailers for
the sequel with paramount clearly having
changed their tune in the last 30 plus
years on the inclusion of tantalizing
sports sequences in their action movies
if fan reactions are anything to go by
this sequel will end up being just as
beloved as the original the movie raked
in more than 400 million dollars
worldwide in its first week of release
and reviews have been overwhelmingly
positive for many the volleyball scene
in the original top gun is simply meant
to function as a bit of eye candy for
viewers for a few glorious moments
audiences get a chance to see some of
the hottest actors from the 1980s in
peak form play around for a little bit
but according to star tom cruise it's
actually more meaningful than that back
in 1986 cruz sat down for an interview
with the los angeles times where he
spoke at length about top gun including
delving into that scene he talked about
how important it was to the overall
story more so than simply offering fun
vibes going on to say first of all it
shows that to fighter pilots physical
prowess is very important plus the scene
shows the constant competition between
these guys how they compete on every
level with tongue firmly in cheek plenty
of people seem to agree that the scene
is incredibly important to the film with
one user on youtube writing without this
scene the plot wouldn't even make any
sense check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about top gun maverick are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you